Now, before we get into some of the minute details of using our physics engine,
let's take a minute, and go through our wish list of what we'd like our physics
engine to do for us. And why it makes our lives a lot simpler. The first thing
is, that we like to be able to create physics objects for each of our game
entities that needs them. We'd also like to be able to update the physics
engine each frame, or rather, we'd like to be able to allow the physics engine
to update itself, and take care of most of the work for us. We'd also to be
able to fire off collision events between different physics objects, and then
respond to them arbitrarily. And finally, we'd really like to be able to pull
updated position information for each of our game physics objects, each frame.
That means effectively, that we can use the physics engines calculations to
feed position information into our rendering engine for drawing next frame. So
to accomplish all of this for grids, we decided to go with a physics engine
called Box2D.